نرحب بمشاهدين فرانس 24
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر
قلق الصينيين الذين ملوا من القيود فجاه
رفع رفعت القيود كليا فانتشر الفيروس من
جديد والحديث عن نصف مليون اصابه يوميا
دول بادرت بفرد فحوصات على الوافدين من
الصين واخرى مثل الدول الاوروبيه تبحث
الموضوع بانتظار تتخذ القرار النهائي لا
يعرف الكثير عن الوضع لا يعرف الكثير عن
الوضع الوبائي في الصين ولا عن طبيعه
اللقاح الصنيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اقترح على
الصين لقاحات
سنحاول ان نفهم العمل لتجنب انتشار
الفيروس ما هي الحلول اذا لم تتوفر
الشفافيه المطلوبه الى اي احد الوضع اصبح
خارج السيطره سعيد بان يناقش الموضوع هنا
في الاستوديو مع اي منار مراد استجاريه
تقدير والانعاش في المستشفى الاوروبي جورج
وهي طبعا جارتنا هنا على بعد امطار من
القناه سعيد بان يكون معي محمود زريق ولو
ان خفت قبل الاعياد عندما رايته بالكمامه
على بيه هام وبروفيسور في علم الاوبئه
والصحه العامه في جامعه فرساي وسعيد بان
تكون معنا دائما رغم الساعه المتاخره من
بكين سعاد يايشين وهي صحفيه صينيه اهلا
وسهلا بكم قبل نبدا نستمع لمقالته
اليزابيث بورن حول هذا الموضوع رئيسه
الوزراء الفرنسيه
حكومتي دورها في حمايه الفرنسيه وذلك بطلب
فحص الكوفيين عند الوصول لجميع الركاب
الذين يستقلون رحله من الصين الى فرنسا
ابتداءا من اليوم
مما يسمح لنا بالحصول على بيانات حول تطور
الفيروس جديده
الوباء تعاون في الصين دوليا للحد من
انتشار كوفيت 19 عقدت السلطات الصينيه
المختصه مؤتمر افتراديا مع منظمه الصحه
العالميه لتبادل وجهه النظر حول وضع
الوباء والمشاكل المتعلقه بالعلاج الطبي
والتطعيم اتفقنا على تبادل المعلومات
للقضاء على الوباء عالميا بسرعه
حاليا في الصين شهد في اجزاء اخرى من
العالم لذلك لا حاج لفرد قيود دخول الى
الصين نؤمن وان اجراءات الوقايه يجب ان
تكون علميه وليست فرصه للتلاعب السياسي
يجب عدم التمييز بين الافراد وان لا يتاثر
التعاون جره ذلك
مايا من بكين سعاد ياي لست ادري ان كنت
عرفتي ذات يوم
فرنسي راحل كتب كتابا اذا اذا استيقظت
الصين فان العالم سيهتز ولكن العالم يهتز
مع ان السين استيقظت اقتصاديا ولكن هناك
مخاوف كبيره هل هذا الشعور متبادل في
الصين هل بالفعل هناك نصف مليون يصابون
يوميا
بالفيروس في الصين حاليا
موجه جديده من انتشار الوفاء ولكن يمكن ان
نعرف ان الزين بعد
تعديل السيادها للوقايه من الوباء همم
يكون هناك اعيش الاقتصاد سيدنا
الاجتماع تدريجيا في الحائر بلاد وايضا
يعني ان اا سينا نتعاملوا على ذلك جاء
بسبب ضعف قدره الامراض للمتحاوره او
ميكروب وارتفاع نسبه عماد بين المواذنين
وتراكم خبرات الحكومه للسيرات على انتشار
الرايس
فان السين بدات على القيود في السيد رعد
على انتشار الوباء منذ ديسمبر الماضي
تاثيرات القيود على تنميه الاقتصاديه
وحيات اليوميه للمواطنين الصينيين كما
تركز جهود السين على
العلاج الثدي للمصابين وانا سين اكدت ان
الوضع الوباء تحت السيطره في الوقت الحالي
وكما يمكن ان نلاحظ انه بعد تحسين تعديل
الزينه لسياسات الوقايه من الوباء تم
تسريع استعاده نظام الاقتصاد والاجتماعي
في السنه ورحب المجتمع الدولي بذلك على
على نطاق الواسع وتعتقد ان القرار سيكون
دافع ايجابيه للاقتصاد العالمي لكن ما بعد
الدول اعلنت الفرد قيود على دخول
المستفيدين من الصين ووصفات الحاله
الوبيعيه في السيد بانها قد تتحولوا الى
سلاسل جديده من الفيروس وتعتقد السينما
مثل الحريري مثل ذريه وليست
علميه وغير مقبوله لدينا نهايه العالم فان
سلاسل فيروس المنتشره في السيده حاليا
كلها قد انتخابات العالم وازاي مكانه
تتداقد اجراءات السيف والركوفيدا للسيطرات
على انتشار الوباء بينما كانت معظم
الاصابات وسلاسل الفيروس قد جاءت من
الوافدين
الاجانب الى السينما حيث كانت موازنه دول
كانت يعني قبل همم قبل يعني رافع القيود
همم في السجن فانت همم بعض الدول انتقد
زينب بانها هي التي هزمت بالحرده الساحل
واجراءات الشديده للسيده بعد على انتشار
الوباء ودعت السنه لفتح ابوابها ولكن
والان يعني في الوقت الحالي بعد رفع قيود
اعتقد هذه الدول
هو احد غير ما قبول
سيتفاعلان معك تفضلي معناها ماذا تتفاعلين
معها حسب مقر الامور تحت السيطره تقول
متوفره في اوروبا حتى هذه اللحظه انها
صحيح ان سياسه السفر كوفيه كانت سياسه
سيئه والسبب بالموضوع انها في حال كانت
مترافقه مع عمليه التطعيم في الصين لكانت
ممتازه هذه السياسيه ولكن ما يحدث
التطعيم قليل نعم والاسوء ان حوالي 60%
اولا نتيجه صفر كوفيه ان الشعب بشكل عام
لم يحصل على المناعه الطبيعيه يعني بمعنى
الاصابه وايضا الاشخاص الذين هم من
المفروض ان ياخذوا عدد من الجرعات لم
ياخذوا الا جرعتين فقط والسبت بملاك يقبل
همم ان جرعتين من اللقاح الصيني تبين هي
طبعا الداتا ليست موجوده لدينا ولكن من
خلال الدول التي لقحت بهذا اللقاح تبين
انا ليكون هناك فعاله لهذا اللقاح يجب على
الاقل ثلاثه جرعات ولكن للاسف انهم حبسوا
المواطنين في بيوتهم ولكن لم يلقحوا
المواطنين وبالتالي الان ما يحدث هو ان
عندما خرج هذا خرج العالم جميعا خرج من
بيوتهم فان هذا الفيروس وانا اتفق مع الز-
همم الزميله الصحفيه انه هو من سلاله
الاومكرون التي موجوده هي في اوروبا ولكن
في كل انحاء العالم ولكن هنالك عدد من
الدول التي لقبت باللقاح الصيني ولكن ثبت
لديها ان هذا غير فعال فاعطت جرعه او
جرعتين من فايزر او من مودرن او من
الاستروجين او الى اخره منها او حتى
اللقاح الروسي من اللقاحات المعتمده ولكن
ما حدث في الصين انا هذه هي وجدوا انا
لقاحهم هو الافضل ولم يعطي لقاح اخر ولم
يستمر بالتلقيح الشيء الاخر انا صحيح ان
هذه السلاليه من سلا من همم تحت
الاوميكرون ولكن ما تخشاه اوروبا كامله
وامريكا والعالم بانه هو متحور جديد لان
عندما ينتقل الفيروس من شخص الى اخر
وينتقل فانه سيشكل نوع المونتاجن حتى هذه
اللحظه ان الجرعه الجديده من لقاح
الفايزير الذي موجود الان بين يدينا هو
فعل الامكرون ولكن ماذا ستكون النتائج بعد
انتشار هذا الفئه هذا ال- هذه النسخه من
الفيروس في الصين والعالم لا نعلم
بسبب ما يجري في الصين
طبعا
سلاماتك كل عام وانتم بخير استاذ
المشاهدين
[موسيقى]
عدد سكانه مليار و400 مليون صح حوالي 20%
من سكان العالم كلياتها هل بلد وحده
100%
انتقال كبير جدا وبشكل مفاجئ من من سياسات
همم شديده وطعميه الى فتح همم
كما كما كما قلت كمان انه
صامعه المناعه الطبيعيه عن طريق العدوى
اللقاحات ما بتاخذ بشكل كويس وفي كمان
بفعاليه اللقاحات الصينيه طبعا ممكن يكون
في خطر همم
انه المعلومات الجايه من الصين
لهلا ما بنعرف بالضبط حضرتك قلت انه عدد
عدد المصابين باليوم 500,000 من 10 ايام
كنا عم نحكي كنا عم نحكي في يوم اصحاح 37
مليون شخص يعني ما يعادل في اذا بناخذ
العاده السكان فرنسا ما يعادل مليونين
حالي بفرنسا باليوم همم كما تعرف فرنسا
اليوم الاعلى اللي صار فيه هو ب- بشهر
كانون الثاني وصافي 500,000 يعني صفحه
اربع خمس مرات همم الحالات الموجوده
عم نحكي كمان انه في في 250 مليون صيني
معه همم
بدون اي توثيق بدون اي معلومات همم واضحه
بدون اي بيانات بدون اي دراسه طبعا هذه لا
يعطي همم ثقه اللي هلا مثلا لانه
المتحولات ال- ال-
المنتشره همم
الصين لمنظمه الصحه العالميه عن لائحه
المتحورات اعطتها عن عينه اقل من 100,000
حالي بس طبعا بالف حاله عن ملايين سووا
التسلسل جنيني شو ما كان همم
المتحورات ما بتعرف
تطوع كذا معلومات قليله جدا وهادي بهذا
بيسوي
اهتمام وحذر من من ما يمكن ان يحدث ثانيا
ببعض انه عدد الحالات اللي بنحكي فيها 250
مليون صيني 37 مليون بيوم واحد اذا كان
صحيح الارقام هائله فعلا معناته معناتها
همم
بتثير همم الخطر الاكبر هو على الشعب
الصيني يعني
همم حائط المناعي ضعيف والاشخاص المسنين
ما عندهم لقاحات وعنده معتى اذا كان في
خوف والخوف على السنين وشفنا بالاقتزاز
المشافي شفنا
بدعوا الاموات وغيرها من ذلك معناته الخطر
الاكبر بالصين وبعدين قد يتصدى قد يتم
تصديره الى العالم
وممكن الخوف طيارتين اخذ طيارتين همم
وصلوا عفوا الطيارتين همم سبت احد ووسطه
على ايطاليا روما ولا ميلان ولا ميلانو
همم نسبه همم
الاصابات واحد على اثنين
همم
ايجابي واحد على اثنين ايجابي محترم تخيل
قديش همم اعدادها اليه همم طبعا هذه طبعا
خطر على الليله مع في خطر همم كمي
ونوعي
بالارقام بنسبه الارقام الكبيره جدا
بالعدوى همم
نوعي عن طريق نسبه انه يصير متحولات جديده
طيب استمعت الى راي طبيبين هناك تفضل
اه وقاعده كده اول اغنيه او شريره انه في
الوقت الحالي تتواجد السيد في فتره تعديل
السياسات الوقايه من الوباء
التي تعتبر فتره ضروريه التي تواجهها كل
الدول في العالم بعد رفقوده سيطرت على
انتشار
لوحدها
يعني وكانه انسان
الامور جاءت فجاه
ههه اولا يعني كما ااا ذكرته في عندما كان
كنا نتحدث عن سياسه كوفيه السويفر كوفيه
ذاتيه في السنه ذكرت ان يعني سينا يعني
لديها الوضع الخاصه او العدد سكانها كبير
جدا وعدد المسنين كبير جدا وكثاف سكنيه
كبيره جدا
يعني همم يعني همم ارتفاع عدد المصبين في
السنه كبيره لان حجم سكان عدد السكان
كبيره اكبر من ما تتمادى به معظم الدول
العالم متى لا يمكن ان همم على سبيل
المثال كندا مساحتها اكبر من الصين ولكن
عدد السكانها 40 مليون نسمه ولكن عدد
السكان لمدينه اكثر من 20 مليون نسمه في
ان ان نرى لا يوجد مقارنه بين الدولتين
فيس كثافه سكانيه فانا يعني كما نعرف ان
الفيروس او كروم يتماته حاليا بانتشار
السريع
وعدوا شديده همم يعني في سن كثافه سكانيه
يعني كبيره فان انتشار السريعه همم يعني
عدد المصابين سيشهدوا ارتفاعا كبيرا هذا
امر طبيعي طبيعي
جاء تعديل سياسات همم سيطره على انشاري
الوباء في السجن بسبب ادعها في القدره هذا
لمتحاور قلوب انا شخصيا وزوجته بالفايروس
ايضا في ديسمبر
كله استماره لحومه ليومين ولما اتناول
ربما ولكن بالنسبه للمتقدمين في السن وغير
الملقحين يمكن ان تتسبب في العديد من ما
زال هناك
ايضا موجود انت موجود حتى الان
مختلف لذلك فان السيد تركز جهودها للوقايه
وسيطرت عليها على حمايه الصحه والوقايه من
الحلات المرضيه الشديده وسيتم يتقاض
المزيد من تدابير لحمايه حياه الشاعر
مساعد
مقارنه بالعديد من الدول في العالم في
الصين
ان يعني انها تتناكن من تدعيم يعني
استخدام اللقاحات بشكل كافي
لتدعيم المواطنين السعوديين كما نعرف ان
الزينه هي من الدول التي تعمل على انتاج
وعلى البحوث العلميه همم
للقاعدات لفيروس
ثانيه يعني اليوم لاول مره الجريد قريبه
من الحزب الشيوعي الصيني اعلانات انا
الوضع قلق في وهذه باول مره في بدايه انه
الوضع مقلق وان الصين طلبت همم الاطباء
المتقاعدين حتى اطباء العنايه المشدده
والكثير استدعتهم للعوده بالعمل في
المشافي وهذا دليل انا اذا استطيع ان
افهمه فهو ان الوضع خارج السيطره يضاف الى
ذلك ان عدد الوفيات حتى الان غير معروف
والسبب ان المعلومات الاوروبيه طبعا
متوفره انا الان وفيات في سجلات الصينيه
لم تعد ان مثلا توفى بكوافيد وانما توفى
بابنومونيا او قصور تنفسي بمعنى انك اذا
اردت ان تراجع سجلات لا يوجد كلمه همم
اضف الى ذلك طبعا ان اللقاحات
الاعراض حتى الاعراض الاوميكرون على شخص
مسن هي قاتله فما بالك للي هو المناعته
صفر وبالتالي انا اظن ان هذه الطريقه بان
ما زالوا يعتبرون ان كل الامور تحت
السيطره وكل الامور تمام الان لم نعد في
همم في مرحله ان همم نعم الان هي خطا قاتل
خطا قاتل الان لاننا وكاننا نعود الى
المربع الاول من جديد ايضا يتكلمون عن
انه اعلى يوجد ايضا بين يوري بنوري او نقص
في عدد الادويه ايضا الموجهه ضد الكوفيد
يعني الانتيفي الانتي فيربس يعني
في الصين
التي كانت موجوده في كل العالم اظن يعني
في هنالك حلقه مفقوده عما يجري في الصين
اردت ان تتفاعل مع سعاد تفضل
ممكن سبب تغيير سياسه الصين من الصفيد لا
انفتاح كامل
طبعا في كان ال ال لضغط الشارع والضغط
السياسي والضغط الاقتصادي على الصين حتى
ممكن انه مفكر انه بهذا المرحله طبيعيه
مش بنايه او اللي عندهم عندهم همم نقص
مناعه على الاقل مليون ونصف لاثنين مليون
صيني سيتم وفاته خلال ثلاثه اربعه اشهر
لكن هو همم لهيك بجوز الصين احد سياسه احد
القاعات اللي ممكن تاخذها لانه سيحدث بدل
ما نبطئ
بدال ما نبطئ همم حصول لهذا بتكون بمره
واحده همم نخلص من هالازمه طيب سعاد عندما
نرى بعض القرارات التي تخذت واعطيكي على
سبيل المثال القرار الذي اتخذته اليابان
مثلا اليابان بالنسبه للوافدين من الصين
هناك الان الزام باسبوع حجر صحي
مع ذلك رغم الفحص الفحص وايضا صحي لمده
اسبوع اذا هناك همم خوف واريد ردك يعني
مساله الشفير يعني لا توجد احصائيات واضحه
من قبل الصين فيما يتعلق في هذا الموضوع
الجديد الذي تواجهها الزينه في انتشار
الروباء يعني ربما هي
تواجهه المعظم الدول في يعني في انتشار
الوباء بعد رفع القيود
سنتين
في فرنسا بنسبه طبعا تطعيم تجاوزت الستين
او قرابه 70% لان الوضع مختلف طبعا منذ
سنتين كنا كذلك والان ولكن الان غير
موجوده اذا الكلام ما موجود لدينا ابدا
هذه الارقام وهذا ال- وهذا الوضع في
المستشفيات لن استطيع تفضلي سعاد
ذروه الاولى من انتشار الوضوء سيكون هناك
يعني تخفيف ولا انتشار فيسينا ايضا يعني
في الوقت همم
المجتمع الثاني
حوار يعادينا
من البيت
كمبيوتر ولكن الصوت راح شويه تفضلي
الشوارع لا يوجد كثير من الناس
وهناك استحمام
يعني الشفاء الدفعه الاولى من الصيني
محمود زريق يتحدث لا يعرف الحديث عن 250
مليون قد تكون اكثر انه
لان بعد رفع القيود فلا نحتاج الى لا لا
تتروب العرس سالم اا اجهزه همم المواطنين
لتلاقي انفاس نووي حدث من جهه
عدد الاشخاص بالعنايه المشدده هاي معلومات
مهمه جدا لا نعرف حتى لو ما كان في عدد
فحوص عن طريق
او البيسير على الاقل عدد الاشخاص
بالمشافي بجوز بجوز يكون فيها همم
هذه المشكله انه بيجوز حضرتك اقل يعني
الارقام المتناقله بشكل غير رسمي ارقام
كبيره
من المصابين في المستشفيات وقت حتى داخل
المستشفيات على الاقل هذه الصور التي وصلت
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
معلومات حتى انا عارف ن الوضع ب بما يحدث
بالسين بشكل طبي هو موضوعي تفضلي
وبعد كده اننا لا يمكن ان يعني همم نركز
جهودنا ونراكز اهميتها في لماذا يعني اللي
حصلت
المعانيه بحدا ال اا يعني بانتشار رواء
واول لا يجب علينا ان نعرف ان معظم الدول
في العالم قدر رفعت قد
انفتحت او قدر بعد قيود بشكل كامل على
انتشار الوباء
بجرعات كامله ثلاثه اربعه
هل كانت هذه الدول لديها احساءات
طبعا طبعا
[ضحك]
كل يوم عدد الوفيات عدد الاصابات
اقل بالصين لهيك لهيك لازم يكون في عنا
معلومات حتى نقدرش الوضع لان
همم
لو كان موجود كان قال عندما تحطه في الصين
ههه العالم كان ههه
يعني المشكله هو الخوف على المواطنين في
الصين قبل كل شيء لانه اذا ما انتشر بهذا
الشكل تفضلي
بس في تعطي امامكم
[موسيقى]
ليس فيها ليست ضروري لان الصينيين في
الوقت الحالي لا يوجد ايقاف كبير همم ايضا
يعني اه ولد همم بعد يعني اصابه همم كثير
من الناس بهذا الوفاء بحذف فايروس ونحن
نعرف ان الارض خفيفه مثل ما يحدث في
موازنه بالنسبه
عفوا خفيفه بالنسبه للملقحين لغير
الملقحين مش خفيفه
يعني الناس
[ضحك]
222 في 40,000 مود صعب في حوالي 500
450,000
استشفاء ارقام عائلي لاني عدد المصابين
كبير طبعا
اسهل بشوي اعراضه اسهل شويه
ولكن انتشار الكبير جدا
وهلا طبعا في اجراءات طبعا مثل حضرتك
اجراءات الدول مثل امريكا
اولا ما في تنسيق لا اوروبيه
له فائده
لا يمكن يمكن
زموني بالفحص واخذ طياره ثانيه ويجعل
باريس احد همم احد الاخطاء طبعا لاني ما
في تنسيق لو في تنسيق لازم يكون
همم
الاجراءات بتكون فات قليله جدا همم ضحيله
جدا جدا بس ممكن دول مثلا انه والله جاي
طياره وفيها 50% من الاشخاص ايجابيه
بعدين همم
التناقض انه انه هل على الاقل ممكن يقل
عدد العالم الاشخاص الموجودين بالطياره
المصابين وممكن نسويه التسلسل الجنين حتى
انا عارف المتحولات والمتحولات الفرعيه
اللي ممكن توصل معه الفائده موجوده علميا
بدها تكون شويه همم لمره جديده
بالنسبه عاليه من الاشخاص اخذوا اللقاح
الجرعه الرابعه والجرعه الخامسه حتى همم
يعني
في في بعض الاشخاص طبعا الحساسين اولاد
لديهم امراض او كبار خمسه
لقاحات ار ان ار ماسنجر هي يعني فعال
ثلاثه ل 4 شهور مكسي مول
اكثر شيء اربع شهور لست شهور طبعا حسب حسب
وضع ال- ال-
امراض شو عنده همم
طياره كامله الجاي فبنا نعرف انه شو يعني
هذا الفيروس كيف عم يتطوى وين عم ينتقل شو
ممكن يعطي هل اللقاحات ما زالت فعاله او
لا هي طبعا غايه علميه لتطوير لقاح جديده
ان امكن يعني الان لقاح الموجود هو فعال
علام يمنع الانتقام يمنع انتقال من شخص
الى اخر ولكن ماذا ستكون النتيجه بعد عده
اشهر لا نعلم وخاصه ان الدلتا ما زال
موجوده طبعا همم اضف الى ذلك ان حتى هذه
الدول الاوروبيه واعتقد انها لانها مطمئنه
قليلا ما زالت ترجح الاقتصاد على الصحه
بمعنى حتى هنا في اوروبا انا نحن بيننا
وضعنا بين ايديكم لقاح طلبنا من جميع
الاشخاص او المرضى ان يتلقوا من لا يريد
اذان ليختار مصيره بنفسه لحد ما هذا ما
يحدث نعم
طيب سعاد هل لدينا فكره مثلا في فرنسا في
اوروبا في الولايات ايه ده نعلم انه حصل
تعديل على التركيبه اللقاح حتى يكون
حتى يتماشى مع فيروس اوميكرون هل مثلا
اللقاح الصيني تطور تدريجيا ام هو نفس
الجرعه التي تلقاها الصيني في بدايه
الجائحه هي الجرعه التي يترقاها حاليا
شو عامل طيب
على تطوير اللقاحات المضاده
جهود السيد في البحوث العلميه في هذا
المجال كبناعرف ان سيدنا
اكبر انتاج واكبر خط انتاج
لقاحات المضاده
لا يوجد مشاكل
تم تحديده في الصين
هل وصلت الى صفر حاله في الصين
في سيطرات علينا
في الوقت الحالي يعني همم اهم شيء هو همم
كيفيه انتعاش الاقتصاد العالمي وليس يعني
همم
هو هو السؤال الذي يريد ان اطرحه عليك
طبعا نتحدث عن تركيبه هذا اللقاح الصيني
ولكن اللقاح الصيني هذا استخدمه في اكثر
من بلد افريقيا وحتى في الدول العربيه حتى
الان هذه الدول
تمكنت من النجاح في الوقايه من الفيروس
مثل بقيه الدول الاوروبيه على حسب
الاحصائيه خاصه في الدول التي توجد فيها
المستشفى كما تحميل من العدوى
والامارات
فقط
[موسيقى]
اذا كان اذا كان الهاتف من الاجراءات اللي
عم تاخذ الدول
الغربيه انه بتمنع الفيروس هذا حلم صحيح
همم
بيكون الهدف مم طب طيب دخوله على على
البلاد حتى نعرف شو خطواته شو كيف انتشاره
حتى تدخل الاجراءات تكون الاحترازيه
المناسبه مناسبه له معناتها هل اجراءات
هذه المحطوطه هلا طبعا
من جديد هدفها بس تبطيء ولم تسمع عن شيء
كبير بس شغل المهم اكثر مهما يكون
المتحولات ومهما تكون المتحولات الفرعيه
سونا بنعرف كيف طريقه الوقايه له وكيف
بيسووا له لانه
بينتقل عن طريق الهواء لازم يسيعه كمامات
ولازم يكون في الاماكن مفتوحه
وقت ومشي على
الاشخاصابه بحالات خطاها لازم اللقاحات
القدامي حتى مهما كان ما سيحدث ومسا ياتي
من الصين
نعرفها من 3 سنين هي نتيجه الدراسات علميه
نتيجه احصاءات وهذا الشيء على الاقل بطمن
طيب اكيد شهد مثل ربما في ال سي هذا
الصباح
طيب هناك متحور امريكي
متحور امريكي
يعني يراوغ للمناعه في الجسم وهذا المتحول
يبدو خطير طبعا في متحوله
عنده عنده بيلعب على المناعه بشكل اكبر من
بقيت المتحورات وخلال بخلال اسبوعين ثلاثه
زاد من 10% الى 40%
ما يحدث بالصين
الولايات المتحده عدد الحالات حاليا هو
اقل من عدد الحلقات
ال 15 حاليا مش في حوالي 10 ايام
بنتشعر بسرعه
بس حابب اقوله انه المشكله مع المتحول
الامريكي انه همم
انه هو همم
بالطياره ما راح يكون نصهم معهن المتحوكي
عدد الاشخاص الايجابيين بطياره جايه من
امريكا
قليل جدا جدا مثل العسل همم عدد الاصابات
الكامله همم مثل همم
من الصين و50 ممكن بقعه همم بس اذا زادت
حالات
مثل بالصين او بشكل كبير جدا طبعا لازم
تكون نفس الاجراءات على على الصين مثل
الاجراءات على امريكا ما في اي ما في اي
مجال همم
[موسيقى]
جان للبعض مثلا هلا في بعض الاشخاص اللي
بيكون مثلا عندهم امراض ثانيه حتى مثلا
ناخذ مثال انا يعني المتحورات لم تعد
تقلقنا طالما هنالك في لقاح مثلا خذ على
سبيل المثال للجريب هذه السنه كل
الاحصائيات الانفلونزا كان في اشخاص
شغلتهم تدرس فقط هل جاء رائحه الانفلونزا
كيف راح تكون فتوقعوا ان هنالك متحول جديد
سيكون كارسي ونصحت جميع الاشخاص بس سواء
اخذ لقاح الكريب للجميع وهي بناء على
الكاتوري المعينه التي التي هي يعني نفسها
تقريبا همم الفئات التي يجب ان تاخذ
بالنسبه للكوفيت وايضا اقترحوا ارتداء
الماس وفي اي لحظه تشتد الاصابات ما زال
لديكم لقاح لاخذه وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لاي
متحور بالنسبه للكوفيه عندما يصدر متحور
جديد ندرس امكانيه اللقاح ندرس هل هو
اللقاح فعال ندرس قديش الامراضيه له نسبه
دخول المستشفيات وعلى اساسها يتم تحويل
يعني تحويل الخطه بينما ما يحدث بس بالصين
لان عالم شيئان الان بعد عامين نغير
السياسه باتجاه كما يجري في الدول
الاوروبيه ولكن شتان بين الاثنين يعني
شتانا سواء بفعاليه اللقاح سواء بالسياسه
سواء بطريقه التفكير كما تعلم نحن نعلم
على الصين اكثر مما هم يعلمون ماذا يحدث
في اوروبا يعني همم طيب سعاد الان فيما
يتعلق بالاجراءات هل مثلا هناك نصائح من
قبل الدوله لضروره ارتداء الكمامه مثلا
للمواطنين همم هناك اجراءات معينه هناك
مخاوف من ربما بعد الى جانب كورونا حالات
انفلونزا وكرونا وهذا اخطر بكثير مما
نتصور
اولا انا اريد
ان رفع القيود وهو
يتناسب مع الوضع على المتغير وهذا من جهه
اخرى اعراض
خفيفه
لعدد كبير كثير من الاشخاص بس الاشخاص
المسنين
همم مقارنه مع مواز متوالي في العالم التي
قد واجه هذاك الفتره قبل يومين ولكن هنا
يجب علينا ان نلاحظ ان الوضع الخاصه بصينا
عدد سكان كبيره وكاله قبل عامين كانت حده
الفيروس وكبيره ولذلك فان سيدنا اذا رفعت
القيود قبل عامين مثلما تفعله الله في
العالم فان الانتشار تكون سريعه وايضا
يعني يكون هناك مصابين ويكون هناك
اكبر من من الوقت الحالي
ولماذا تفعل همم اعتقدت السيده
لمده ثلاث سنوات لان يعني الوداع الخاصه
بالسين عدد سكان كبيره عدد المسلمين كبيره
وايضا يعني همم
[موسيقى]
انتظار سيدنا
عماد بين المواطنين
وفي الوقت الحالي اعتقد كل هذه الظروف
جاهزه وكنا همم انسينا بدات به السيد رائع
رافع القيود على السيطره همم سيطره اعلى
انتشار الوفاء
بقي على الدول
اذا اذا الادويه ادويه الكوفيت او غير
الادويه ببصت على العالم
بس انا الحقيقه عندي سؤال بالنسبه لما يخص
منظمه الصحه العالميه يعني ما في اي
كونترول يعني بلد لم يلقح مثل الصين لم
يلقح شعبه الا بلقاحين فقط يعني ما في
طريقه لاجبار وكان منذ زمن طويل
الصين
[موسيقى]
وبيفيد كمان للجريب
هذه مهم جدا لان المشافي عدد حالات
الانفلونزا اكثر من عدد حالات الكوفيين
بالمشافي حاليا بفرنسا طبعا ذوب حجرين
الموقف حتى من اوروبا باعتبر اجتمعوا لم
يتخذوا بعد قرار ينتظرون
لمحاوله توحيد الموقف واتخان الاقتصاد
طبعا
والصناعه الصينيه
همم سياسه الصحه اعمله ما بتعتمد على
فيتو لازم تكون
في الكتاب مراد